of the unprecedented dangerous nature of
this raid fox news contributor jonathan
turley uh jonathan in light of what john
is reporting and what we now heard from
the president's own attorney
um as as recently as june they
they were communicating they actually
went to mar-a-lago they saw the
documents in the box they requested a
padlock be put on that particular room
that request was granted and they were
also offered complete access anytime
they wanted it why this then
well that's the question the more we
learn the more confusing this gets what
what did they possibly tell reinhardt
did they relay this history to the
magistrate that according to these
sources that the president had
cooperated i mean the idea that he was
subject to a subpoena complied with the
subpoena didn't challenge it
voluntarily showed the storage room to
the agents i followed their advice
secured it
to to meet their demands
all of that is hardly a basis for saying
now we need to send in 40
fbi agents on a nighttime rate i mean if
the subpoena worked the first time then
presumably a second subpoena would work
the second time if there were remaining
documents that were not gathered up in
the first collection what we have to
find out is the details you know there's
a suggestion of this confidential source
what was alleged in these papers
do they really suggest there was a risk
of destruction or active concealment
those are the things we're going to have
to be looking at and as for the recusal
report that you just heard obviously
that's really quite odd i mean if he
recused himself the first time it's it's
it's rather odd to see himself executing
such an important uh search warrant uh
just a little while later unless there
was something about the first case or
circumstance that had an added conflict
of interest
we'll have to find that out as well so
what does this all mean
it means it means that we're not
learning facts that the attorney general
could easily share with us without
compromising this investigation
you know my gut tells me that this never
had anything to do with the presidential
records act or the national archives
jonathan turley it has all the markings
to me of a fishing expedition
uh that's my gut instinct what is yours
well you know this has been a theory of
many people that this was a pretext for
gathering january 6 material if that's
the case it's truly breathtaking because
this is the same agency that has a
documented history of misrepresenting
facts to judges falsifying material
being given to secure search warrants if
this is a repeat of that conduct then
there will be held to pay
if there's an oversight investigation
great analysis as always you've been on
your game a game all week i've been
watching jonathan turley thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else